un grand soleil pour les vendanges c'est
le grain de raisin sur le gâteau pour
couronner une année météo idéale sur la
côte viticole il y à la quantité il y a
la qualité et le bureau
interprofessionnel des vins de bourgogne
confirme comme chaque année les
prélèvements effectués sur ces parcelles
de références viennent tout juste d'être
analysé on analyse les principaux
paramètres intéressant c'est à les
sucres l'acidité le péage les acides
organiques
le raisin est de très bonne qualité donc
ça laisse supposer eh ben on va
également mais derrière il ya la patte
du vinificateur qui vit en plus et qui
permet d'apporter la touche du domaine à
partir du même vendanges vous mettez ça
dans les mains de deux vinificateur qui
peuvent être un petit peu différent
et quand le raisin est bon bien mûres et
sucrés ça facilite le travail du
vinificateur l'idée c'est de essayé de
laisser le vin travailler tout seul sans
trop intervenir pour essayer de ne pas
standardisé et de niveler les vins c'est
un millésime qui pour le 2ème
constitutive conjugue enfin quantité et
qualité et croyez moi depuis 2009
on a souffert on a perdu quasiment trois
récoltes en sept ans donc la bourgogne
renoue enfin pour la deuxième année avec
la quantité mais aussi surtout avec la
qualité notamment pour les rouges où je
pense qu'un grand millésime s'annonce
peut-être comme 99 ou 2009
voilà avec des maturités des richesse en
sucre assez élevé à l'état sanitaire
parfait ce qui augure peut-être d'un
très grand millésime en rouge
beaucoup de bons raisins de la nouvelle
est donc excellente pour le vigneron
reste à savoir si elle le sera aussi
pour le consommateur ce qui est moins
rare pourrait être moins cher on peut
s'attendre à une pondération des prix
effectivement sur les entrées de gamme
puisqu'il y aura moins de tension sur
les entrées de gamme
ça va ça va possiblement avoir une
influence pour stabiliser le plus haut
de gamme mais il n'y aura pas forcément
de révolution non plus sur le plus haut
de gamme
seul petit bémol il en fallait un le
faible taux d'acidité et l'acidité c'est
la charpente du vin blanc mais ça ce
sera le travail du vinificateur le rouge
et dans les cuves prochainement dans
toutes les bonnes cave du soleil en
bouteille qui pourra travailler quelques
années à tenir toutes les promesses de
ce millésime
on va